j'ajouterai ce que vous venez de dire
que les plus jeunes d'entre nous ne nous
regarde pas simplement sur autre chose
que les gens qui ne regardent pas toutes
les missions ils ne regardent qu'une
partie de ce qu'on leur a dit c'est à
dire quand même pas la totalité mais un
sketch ou bien un moment donc ça devient
dramatique mois ce qui moi je suis
d'accord avec monsieur macro
sauf que ça concerne toutes les
télévisions et pas simplement à ceux des
lions public tf1 est démodé m6 est
démodé
toutes les télévisions sont démodés et
mais pour ce qui concerne français
vision que je connais un tout petit peu
plus à dire le problème de la
gouvernance de france télévisions il se
pose pas de la manière dont il l'a posée
c'est simplement que c'est ce groupe
france télévisions est bien jusque dans
les années 95 avait un président nommé
par les politiques pour trois ans
seulement est désormais cinq ans et
jamais aucun d'entre eux on est moins
bien jamais aucun d'entre eux n'a été
renouvelé
comment voulez vous gouverner une
entreprise si votre limite de temps ces
trois ans et cinq ans et pourtant je
veux dire si nous existons encore c'est
que c'est pas que nous sommes bons c'est
que les autres ne sont pas si bons que
ça c'est ça le vrai problème
deuxièmement pour ce qui concerne france
télévisions il y avait des choses
simples à faire en dehors de d'aller
vers le digital et caetera et de répéter
ce que vous avez dit à l'instant c'est
simplement il ya des économies à faire
mais quand vous parler d'économie par
exemple les députés à paris qui viennent
des régions boudisseau faire des
économies sur france 3 mais si sur le
quai de la gare de nantes ou de lens ou
de lille il n'y a pas un journalise le
france 3 pour venir les accueillir ils
se demandent comment ils vont être réélu
donc sont pas à une contradiction près
ensuite quand vous proposer des
économies en faisant des choses simples
ça il ya eu beaucoup de de patron des
lions qui étaient des anciens de l'ena
vous savez de réponse à l'ena pour pas
le faire c'est c'est pas aussi simple
que vous le pensez c'est à dire je me
dégonfle mais où c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué que vous l'imaginez vous avez
deux variantes c'est la même chose on va
rien faire je suis pas là pour longtemps
vous n'avez pas m'emmerder 1 par exemple
qu'en france ô qui coûte plus de 30
millions par an aujourd'hui
france ô ce sont les députés ultramarins
qui est dit nous ne voulons pas du
france ô que nous avons fait avec vos
programmes nous voulions simplement ce
que soient retransmises en france les
bulletins d'information des territoires
et départements d'outre-mer premier
budget de france au camp ça a été créé 4
millions d'euros voilà donc voilà des
choses simples mais ils ne font même pas
ce que demande
on ne fait même pas ce que demandent les
gens là il y aurait même pas eu ce
problème dont on a besoin de 50 millions
d'économies cette année moi je vous en
ai trouvé 30
perry qu il manque 20 millions à trouver
un surnom de la république et
outrancière mais elle est fondée je
respecte mes confrères et collègues
la télévision française comme nicolas
labelle il s'est vraiment à vendre
c'est quand même un mammouth d'avoir
c'est vrai que tous les médias sont
confrontés aux mêmes dérives au même